I have bersitis in both legs, fibrobiology, and Hashimoto's. I now eat a plant-based
whole food diet. It's been a great process of education and experience. Five years ago, I did a new,
I did a new physical therapy exercise that flared both hips so bad that the left leg and hip.
Down is still overreacting. It put me into the worst fibrobiology player I have ever had. I was
flair-free for close to a year at that point. Unfortunately, I had to do corner zone
injections and around the predisode to calm down the inflammation. I can finally walk with
assisted, assisted devices and slowly have been able to walk a block or so. I recently have had
my left side start to seize up again. The stretches, I have to be very careful. I am
over-stretcher. Gentile yoga, dry needle aid and cupping massage seem to help, but then it's like
the hip muscles and left leg muscles grab and go let up. Is there anything you can do that would help?
I have learned by my feedback techniques to release muscle tension, but it doesn't help much
after walking activity. I don't know if I don't know who asked this question, but I don't know if
you have enjoyed our product disease and autoimmune course. If you go to our website cuttersclinic.com,
you'll see up at the top. I have courses, so I've created courses for people to try to help them
educate, get educated and how to self-care. Because I believe we're moving into a time where
you have to take responsibility for your health. This person was obviously doing that and asking
good questions. But you'll find in with an autoimmune disease, so let's talk about it. Versitis
in both hips. Versitis in both hips could be just from a local injury. You could have inflammation
because of the local injury. You could also have versitis and joint issues that are from systemic
inflammation. So in the systemic inflammation, we can be due to an autoimmune
player. Now, person has fibromyalgia. What's fibromyalgia? Fibromyalgia is just a collection of
symptoms. It's not a disease in itself. It's coming from something. So many times people with
fibromyalgia actually have antibodies, self-antibodies, to their muscle tissue, and or their
biology cells in the brain, and or their fibers in the muscles that cause contraction,
and or our arthritis, our thoracic antibodies, or rheumatoid antibodies, it just goes on and on.
So fibromyalgia is caused from something we'd want to find out what antibodies this person has.
Hashimoto's is antibodies to either thyroid globular antibodies or TPO antibodies. That's to your
thyroid gland. So first case, first step, as far as if I was going to manage this case, we'd
want to get a xy-rex array five, and maybe even a xy-rex array seven x. Panel on this person,
those are blood tests to find out what antibodies you have, so that we know what we're dealing with.
That's going to be more diagnostic to give us, okay, this is what is going on. That as far as how to
treat it, is that when you have self-antibodies, so we already know this person, you already know you have
a diagnosis of Hashimoto's, you already know you have TPO antibodies or thyroid globular antibodies,
so we have antibodies to the thyroid gland. So whenever you have a diagnosis of autoimmune disease,
aka antibodies to any self tissue whatsoever, there's anything can flare it from physical activity,
that's too great, physical injury, which can increase cytokine activity, which is inflammatory,
and that's can flare up the autoimmune disease, it just caused this giant snowball effect flare
to exposure to a toxin or a mold or a food that you have an antibody against. These are things
that cause flares, so you alluded to that term flare. So from an autoimmune perspective,
we call it a trigger, so what is the trigger that's causing the flare? That's what we need to identify.
Whenever you're dealing with an autoimmune disease, you've got to find your triggers,
you do, I mean, you're never going to win if you don't figure out your triggers and they can change.
So running a food panel, which would be like a Syrex array 10 food panel,
looking at the gut issues that you might have, which would be a Syrex array too. So Syrex has the
best antibody panel, that's why I keep using that lab's name in the answer to this question.
So looking at the level of leaky gut that a person has, do they have paracelular leaky gut,
do they have trancellular leaky gut, do they have lipopolysaccharides, antibodies to lipopolysaccharides,
which would be the worst level of leaky gut, do they have antibodies, one other self tissue,
do they have antibodies against, and then what foods do they have antibodies against,
that at least we know we need to eliminate those triggers. And then do we need to run a
a microtoxin test or another full toxin load test to see what exposure that you have to
different things that could be causing triggers, that could be a trigger that are causing flares.
So that's how you need to figure this out. For a neat standpoint, as far as
nutritive things that you want to do, it would be a good thing to get on like an autoimmune diet
right off the back, even before you're checking these things, to make sure that you're not taking any
immune stimulants. This is probably the number one thing that we see with people that maybe even know
they have an autoimmune disease, they have Hashimoto's, and then they're taking vitamin C and
garlic and echinacea and all these immune stimulants on a regular daily basis. You can't do that.
Bad alone is going to be a trigger. You can't stimulate your immune system.
What are you going to kill if you stimulate your immune system, you're going to kill that what you
have antibodies against first, which is self tissue. You're going to cause these flares. So you've
got to get off of all immune stimulants. As far as supplementation, the things that a person should
be on in general would be the flavonoids. The anti-inflammatory nutrition, like curcumin,
Boswellia, white willow bark, and things that are going to call the TH for the response,
rosemary, corsets, and things like that. We have to uncover the onion a little bit and see what
lanyards that we're dealing with. I hope that helps. So if you, if whoever asks this question,
if you have a practitioner that you're working with, show them this video, if you're wrong.
You don't have a practitioner, you can make an appointment with me. If anybody listens to this,
if you do want to make an appointment with me, you can just go to our website colors clinic.com
and you can self-schedule or you can call the office if you want to,
we discuss the possible ways to work with us. If you schedule, we call the case review,
which is your initial consultation. We don't take everybody as members slash patients, but
I think I can help you then we work to here, then we can work together, but I don't think I can
help you. I think you could do better served locally than I'll tell you that too. So hopefully I
helped you answer that question.